welcome everyone to another APEC
developer office hours I'm joined here
today by ina with diwani I guess who's
here from Hyderabad Tony can from hong
kong hi everyone and I am Ankur Kotwal
from Sydney so for those of you that
haven't joined us before developer APEC
office hours is all about you asking us
questions live and we try our best to
give you responses to them so these are
developer questions focusing on
developing on android so we have a
Google moderator link and you can post
questions on there and yeah so you can
you can feel free to do so it's on the
Google event and we will put the link
again just as a reminder on the thread
for the Hangout itself so with that
let's go to the first question okay so
thanks for the answers so I guess this
doesn't joined us last time sorry I
couldn't join the last time my question
is related to the secure element access
and selection in my case my phone has to
secure elements and both are having the
same base IVs which one will be selected
over NFC so typically I haven't seen too
many devices with more than one NFC
device so it's pretty cool that you have
a fun with with two I should probably
clear up one thing there's the secure
element is something that we haven't got
a P is for yet it's a secular element
because we wanted to make sure that it
doesn't get abused and it is used so
there aren't any other Pacific yourself
by talking about how to access the NFC
adapter
the well distinguishing between those
two NFC adapters again there's actually
not a good API for that now if you look
at the NFC adapter class for the NFC
manager class you can say give me
default device but you can actually say
give me a specific device so right now
it's going to give you whichever one it
considers to be the default and it also
depends on what you're doing with NFC
because if you're integrating with sort
of the Android Beam type technology you
need to do that just you I mean that's
attractive for you so just override the
right methods there and implement beam
support that way so if you don't really
lower level NFC then it's going to be
different just a quick note I think we
have jump jumping between your screen
and in the moderator screen constantly
so maybe we need to text articles or
four for the recording sure thanks I'm
okay next question low-level media will
future versions support decoding de
muxing two byte arrays and encoding /
maxing from byte arrays or bitmaps or
sound samples as opposed to the
microphone and speaker any what you want
to take this one yep so one thing we
would like to say is a we don't really
have media experts with us today we had
a session from North America about
low-level media api's but we'll try our
best to answer these but it just in case
we cannot be forwarded to our team etha
North America so with future versions
support decoding d muxing so right now
we have with the new low-level media
api's we have a way of providing a byte
buffer to a decoder or an encoder and in
queue a buffer using a byte buffer which
you can create so that's one way of
doing it yeah if the future I don't
really know and I guess we can't really
tell you right now
Thank You uneven so again another
low-level media question can leach state
lib stage fright classes be used in Jay
and I code somehow it says Jay and I
versus Android source tree
incompatibilities and stable native
interfaces I'm actually not an expert in
the the low-level media side of things
and I actually didn't understand what
you mean by the the second part of the
question in terms of Lynch Lynch stage
fright I'm not sure what we'll do is
again will we today basically just say
no that we have a lot of low-level media
questions from Marcus in Europe and
unfortunately we don't have any
low-level media experts on the Hangout
today so what we'll do is we'll forward
it to the the engineering team and ask
the relevant developers and we'll try
and get responses to you in a future
hang up so yeah I don't know the answer
to this particular question how about
you guys oh no not for this one um also
just a just a quick note about on for
four people once you look at the list of
questions that they can actually pinned
the screen for or the moderator so if
you if you want to just go under the
people tab the session you can just pin
down the other on the moderator screen
um if you want to look at the question
is are just a small tube I'll take the
next question so the next question is
are kampala arm in effect of then jar
java are androids now which all people
who use mobile phones my question is if
it goes to an education purpose or
tablet how can we protect them from high
maturity content how to block the porn
sites and apps by default on the OS so
first of all I think this this one is
not really a developer question but uh
but we
we're going to answer it is anyway so
one thing about a maturity content is in
Google Play there is a content filter
our parents can enable so you can set a
setting to high maturity and and then
give it the pin are so for children they
can also this way we can filter out all
the other other maturity contents from
google play store um another thing i
want to point out is this is not really
a specific a problem on on mobile this
is just in general problem on uneven
desktop environment I guess like is
really also we also need to rely on
parents and also our teachers to to help
to fight this like this issue I'd like
to add something to that I know some
educational institutions that I that are
using google apps account as their
university account so domain accounts to
deploy these devices provision with
those accounts so with google apps you
have certainly have some filters
relating to mature content and so if if
you're provisioning the accounts for
your students using google apps you have
a natural way of filtering that at the
domain level or at the account level
before android to you you can find some
policies there the other one is ask
google device administrator you also
have some control over some policies
over the device if the device if the
account is attached to a domain for
example you can can say camera is not
allowed or stuff like that but yes those
are some of the other options you can
think of yeah and I'll just I'll just
bring this back to developers and just
say this is why it's really important
when you publish an app on Google Play
that you've rated accordingly it's one
it's the right thing to do but to it's
actually against our policy to to read
something as being universally available
when it should be targeted at a mature
age group so just keep that in mind
this oh and one last thing I want to add
this in google play we do have a policy
to 44 nudity comic-con tennis is not
it's not allowing google play at all so
um but if anyone you user or developer
see these contents please report those
to us and we will take the action to
take those apps down all right thanks
everyone so next question I have several
apps on Google Play but when I search
for my apps on through a google search I
realized that other app other websites
are also selling my apps on their sites
is there a way to protect my apps from
being sold on unauthorized sites and the
answer is yes what you should be using
is what we have something that we have
called license verification library I
brought up the the page here which is
the relevant section but basically what
you're doing is your app is is making a
call to Google Play to confirm whether
the app has been purchased by that user
or not and and it's particularly
important that I mean here we're talking
about the issue where you know it's been
uploaded to other sites but in general
to combat piracy the LVL is certainly
one way to do it so I suggest you go
through this application licensing
section on on the developer.android.com
site the other thing is I mean there's a
couple of things to keep in mind here
one is that you want to use LVL to
detect whether you know the app has been
pirated or being badly sold but it's
important that you don't just totally
destroy the users experience of your app
because if they've installed your app
and they're actually you know using it
then you can see this as an opportunity
to try and convince them to purchase it
at the right place so I linked it to the
Play Store you may argue that there's
isn't it it may or may not you might not
get too many people that will do this
that you know convert from being a
pirate to being a legit
a paid user but in a way what the way
you should look at it is even if you
only convert a small percentage of them
those are a small percentage that you
wouldn't have otherwise been paid for
paid by so it's really important that
you you look at this but make sure that
you don't implement it in a way that
degrades the experience for people that
have already purchased it so make sure
you think about you know the offline
scenario when somebody hops onto a plane
and they're using your app if the LVL
check is not able to succeed at at that
point because the device is offline
don't block the user from from using
your app so there is a fine balance but
the service helps you the last thing I
really should add is that oh the elders
sorry i'm just going to mute on the
Hangout yep sorry Andrew but LVL
basically we provided as an open source
implementation so it's a library you can
grab it you can incorporate it into your
into your app you need to make sure that
you modify that source code don't just
implement it the way it is because there
are people that are you know writing
automated tools to try and crack
software so if you implement that source
code the same way that it is now that
that license checking people are going
to defeat it you need to come up with a
unique implementation and that's why it
is open source we've tried to be as
transparent as possible there do you
guys want to add anything and on your
door Tony you know if things good does
that just one thing on that one does
that mean that then you have to include
extra permissions for using the Internet
so if you've got an app that would have
maybe one or two permissions you didn't
have to add extra permissions to just to
use the the license and verification I
think that is true so yes you'd probably
need internet permission for that
Network permission yeah okay we have
another low-level media question from
Marcus is there or will there be any
supported way to
stream live video and audio I knew it I
i I'm not sure if there are any
high-level application api's but
suddenly possible I mean many apps do it
many video conferencing apps and
streaming videos and audio so I I don't
know of any particular high level API Oh
stuck in justice we can just say starts
cream or something like that but it's
definitely possible yeah okay next one
will the camera service unlock feature
in future versions so a crashed app
doesn't block the camera for every other
app until the phone is rebooted so I
think Marcus is actually reporting an
issue where if an app let's grab the
camera service crashes that it's it's
locking out other apps from using the
camera I haven't heard of this
particular issue and so if it exists we
should certainly we will certainly
funnel it through to the engineering
team and you know it's something that we
should also include in our compatibility
testing suite to to make sure that it's
it's generally reliable everywhere so
thanks for that Marcus Andrew by default
the droid sans font is used on earlier
versions of Android with the new Roboto
font is that only used on for direx
devices or do you need to use the holo
theme if Roboto is automatically used is
there a way to force droid sans that's a
very good question when you certainly
when you use the holo theme it will use
the Roboto font i believe the droid sans
font is still there to ensure backward
compatibility anything else that I never
thought Tony want to add to that so i
guess like arm if you want to if you
want to use the joists and phones like
probabilities is something you you
to / / / write the theme the holo theme
right boo on top of it yeah I'm not
using the holo theme I just wanted to
make sure that when yeah and my apt runs
on all the different devices is going to
use the same font across all of them
yessir my understanding is that that
we've still kept the droid sans font and
I think it might even have to do with
which SDK version you're targeting okay
as to whether it picks it up or not
certainly switching to the holo theme
will will enable it okay cool okay the
liberal media again is there a way to
record multiple video seemed streams
seamlessly in brackets without the gap
in between the end of one and the start
of the next recording not to my
knowledge under it no I don't know the
answer to this one yeah sorry we just
are we we've obviously been bombarded
with the low-level media questions this
week and we are we're not expert at that
at that low level basically okay ah it
seems to be commentary the media API
seem to be developed for the sole use
case of recording single short files to
disc and playing it back well there were
other use cases like live video
conferencing on a camera smartphone or
simple video editing even concern
considered so I don't have any insight
into what's happened at the the design
side of things but we've got we've got a
video editor on that ships with the the
recent devices and I certainly seen
video editing software on play so there
are people that are doing this with the
high level API is that we already
provide so yeah I'm sure there's a way
to do it yeah how do
detective and audio codec is not
supported well for starters we on the
Android developer website we actually
have a list of supported media formats
and these ones are the ones that will be
guaranteed to be supported across
devices because it's it's it's a part of
the certification process for the
platform itself now obviously with
different versions of Android you know
the the the support has has grown and
grown so what I suggest you do is is
look through these this particular
document and and then you can see which
which formats are officially supported
versus which ones you might you know
which are definitely maybe as i like to
call them because they could be value
ads by the by the OEMs yeah i guess um
Marcus question maybe also the artists
other part of the question could be like
is there a way to detect the list of
supported codecs are dynamically based
on the phone um in jellybean we have a
new class introduced call a media codec
lists are so they are causing that class
you can you can query on the cell phone
by what kind of media codecs is
currently support on that device so but
unfortunately is only available in in
API level 16 but hopefully in the future
that will be useful for for future
phones yeah all right thanks Tony so I
didn't see any more questions on the on
the the thread Andrew did you have any
more that you hadn't put up a moderator
yet and now i just had one question how
do i get hold of an android t-shirt with
jelly bean on the film not sure yet in
the past we've you know we have the
Google store and we've had them we've
sold these these t-shirts there in the
past so these are kind of hot off the
press so we thought we'd get them out
today so right we've also given some of
those through communities through the GD
geez and gtalk so yeah justjust belanger
on your side me might just send you a
box catchment the next gejjen yeah all
right well that concludes the Q&A part
of the the show for this week but we
wanted to just cover a few announcements
that we've we've had so the first one
I'd like to talk about is actually about
the show itself there are some changes
afoot and we're going to be changing the
way we do this show next week onwards so
I don't want to go into the details but
stay tuned we're hoping that these will
be that these changes are an improvement
we've been listening to all the feedback
that we've been getting and we've been
trying to implement as much of it as
possible all right the the other things
that I wanted to mention are relating to
some news that we've had during the week
so firstly we have an update for the
Android SDK tools this is mainly just a
minor bug fix and but on top of that
we're also we've updated the Android
support library so we have a new
notification builder API to try and sort
of add some backward compatibility for
some of the cool new notifications that
that we introduced in in jelly bean so
worth your while to to go and update
your through the SDK manager just keep
in mind that there was a bug that was
there in the SDK manager where the
update may not show up so as the post
says just you might need to go into
packages and then hit the reload option
to refresh the SDK manager cash so that
that that the update shows up next thing
one of my favorite websites is the
Android design website so
at developer.android.com / design it'll
add the index dot HTML part for you you
don't need to put that in yourself but
this is this has been a great website
that we introduced i think around
december january december two thousand
eleven january this year and basically
it covers all of the great design
guidelines that we follow when when
developing our own android apps so we've
had some new updates that this side that
we that we put put live this week so
it's certainly worth your while going in
and checking those out so things like
whether you know how to confirm an
acknowledged input from the user and it
goes through all of this in some in some
great detail and it'll help you add that
that level of Polish you know when are
you asking too many questions when are
you asking the right questions as you
all we'll know you don't want to
approach mobile development with a very
desktop centric mindset so this this
particular section is really grateful
for just explaining how it should work
so the same thing when it comes to his
selection and the the selection side is
actually just talking about how we've
transitioned using the contextual action
bar now instead of having a pop-up for
four menus there's now a new section on
widgets and including the the sort of
the updated widgets that we have like
for the gallery for example and you know
the resizing and so on and so forth so
it's a it's really really interesting as
you all know we just add a great user
experience it's a way that I mean if you
think about it from from a developer
standpoint if a if a user is putting the
your widget on their home screen you
have an opportunity to draw users into
your content this is dynamic content
that you are updating and it is so much
more powerful than just having your app
icon on their home screen because you
can change the content you can you know
alert users to change
images that will again you mean you're
giving your given the opportunity to
invite the men's so widgets are really
important and you know in the future
will we'd love to talk to you about how
to make it well known to your users that
you have a widget how do you help them
discover that there's certainly a topic
we would like to discuss in the future
so that's which its notifications
obviously there was there was tons of
information on notification before but
in jellybean we added rich notifications
so with these rich notifications you can
expand them and have all sorts of
beautiful images and so again the design
site is is going through and and
describing what that experience should
be like the design side is is more live
literally for designers so it's not
showing you code but all you have to do
is flick from the design section to the
develop section to jump to the relevant
code pieces and finally settings this is
actually a section i think we introduced
a little while ago but it's still fairly
new and it just talks about how what
things should be settings you know when
is a right to offer a setting for for a
particular option and finally i'm going
to close off with the section that we
introduced called videos so Google i/o
this year there was a whole range of
videos on the design process when it
comes to designing and Android app so
we've basically collated and grouped
these android design videos on one
convenient page so you can watch them
all in one go and so you know for for
budding designers or Android designers
these these videos are really really
really useful some some great tips there
so that's pretty much it from what's new
with with Android this week what about
Tony and only with anything anything
else um nothing nothing much so all
right well if that's it then thank you
very much for tuning in this week and
we'll catch you next week with some big
changes
all right thank you guys all right have
a nice one